[Musik]
philipp mittelberger auf dem weg zum
brötchenholen
[Musik]
die fliegende badewanne marke eigenbau
ist nur eine der rund 20 verrückten
erfindungen der youtube zwillinge der
real life
heute wollen philipp und johannes mocken
wecker ein kinder fahrzeug gegen einen
kleinwagen antreten lassen
dafür soll das spielzeug einen motor
bekommen wie immer bauen die 22-jährigen
alles selbst eigentlich nichts zu sagen
uns alles er mit youtube tutorials
beigebracht schon alles irgendwie
gegoogelt
unser vater hat uns auch ein bisschen
geholfen am anfang mit fahrrädern zu
passen und so die elterliche garage in
der nähe von frankfurt am main dient als
werkstatt damit das tretauto das
körpergewicht eines jungen erwachsenen
halten kann
schweißen die brüder ein zusätzliches
stahlgerüst 1 der motor läuft akku
betrieben
[Musik]
ja das problem weil das unendlich viel
strom ist er durch historiker und
explodiert ist der letzte deswegen haben
jetzt ewig an gebrauchten motor zu
finden und die wirklich versuchen strom
gemacht sind
ich hoffe mal das jetzt nicht wieder
hochgeht mindestens 2016 begannen die
eineiigen zwillingen damit ihre erfinder
videos auf youtube zu posten
mittlerweile werden sie bei den meisten
aktionen von sponsoren unterstützt mit
ihren projekten möchten die real life
das andere motivieren selbst aktiv zu
werden
das war ziemlich eindeutig vom computer
sitzen und gar nicht mehr was draußen
machen wenn ich glaub das gefühl
irgendwie was selber draußen zu machen
ist immer noch 1000 mittlerweile hat ihr
youtube kanal rund 940.000 abonnenten
die beiden können inzwischen
hauptberuflich davon leben ihr
ingenieursstudium haben sie abgebrochen
das praktische arbeiten liegt ihnen mehr
zum beispiel der bau eines motorisierten
360° schaukelstuhl
[Musik]
wir werden mal damit auf seiner in den
skatepark
diese am randen und dann fahren das war
ziemlich spektakulär dass man wirklich
richtig schlecht geworden dabei eine
menge aufsehen erregte auch dieses
objekt ja dass unser board ich glaube
das ist wirklich das bekannteste aber
auch das gefährlich so dass neben als
gebaut haben nutzt du zu halten da wird
es nicht ja wir machen schon manchmal
gefährliche sachen aber wir versuchen
schon mal aufzupassen vorher halt
abzuschätzen was irgendwie zu riskant
dessen was man noch machen kann also
hier hat mir zum beispiel ein taucher
dabei werden drin sauerstoffflasche und
seil hat mir dran sie haben es
eigentlich und abgesichert
zeit für die nächste herausforderung das
tretauto ist startklar
mit einer motorleistung von 20 ps
johannes tritt damit gegen seinen bruder
philipp an
im 90 ps starken kleinwagen ich glaube
schon dass die beschleunigung von dem
ding ist jetzt ultras aber um die
höchstgeschwindigkeit nicht so also
müssen wir schauen dass wir am anfang
richtig raus hauen damit wir nach
ausreden
meistens helfen freunde der zwillinge
mit wie hier beim aufbau einer karton
mauer als ziellinie nach 200 metern
[Musik]
am anfang als richtig reingehauen aber
am ende hab schon gemerkt nicht
schneller geworden
[Musik]
die ideen gehen den beiden erfindern
jedenfalls so schnell nicht aus ein
fliegendes auto ist schon in planung